they're all around us in public and
personal applications electromagnetic
fields from mobile phones to navigation
systems pylons to medical diagnostics
yet little is known about their effects
on human physiology one reason why it's
taken many years to craft europe-wide
legislation to protect people working
beside high electromagnetic activity
we have no evidence of possible
long-term effects so what we've tried to
do
is put in place a comprehensive package
that had certain values to protect
workers a proposal drafted almost 10
years ago was shelved because the
permissible exposure limits it set were
so strict it would have blocked many
applications including life-saving
medical techniques like mri magnetic
resonance imaging leaving doctors no
choice but to use equipment known to be
harmful
mri is important because it prevents
patients and physicians and other
healthcare professionals to
avoid the risk of having radiology the
first people who had problems with
radialism themselves who got cancerous
of the skin doing radiographies without
any protection measure we care for the
safety of the patients
and for the safety of the medical staff
for the medical employees who are many
times have to be very close to
vulnerable people to older individuals
two children etc meps are demanding
employers assess and reduce workers
exposure but there are exemptions under
some circumstances including the medical
profession and the military
the mep guiding the new rules through
parliament says she's also demanding
officials keep up to speed with research
it is evolution technology
the issue will be debated and voted on
in this week's plenary session in
strasbourg